heute wird alles ausdiskutiert bis zum
letzten Exzess und dazu dadurch wird
jede kleinste Meinungsverschiedenheit zu einem
Riesenproblem aufgebaut wir haben vollkommen
unsere Relationen verloren was ist Ihnen Amerika
noch viel schlimmer und am schlimmsten ist es an
den amerikanischen Elite Unis in Harvard
verlangen Jura Studentinnen dass das Thema
Vergewaltigung aus dem Lehrplan gestrichen
wird weil es Traumata wiederbeleben könnte
in Philadelphia darf das Buch Huckleberry Finn
nicht mehr behandelt werden weil sich schwarze
Studenten diskriminiert fühlen könnten in Berkley
hat man aus Rücksicht auf die amerikanischen
Ureinwohner jetzt sogar den Columbus der
umbenannt in Tag der indigenen Völker was ich
noch irritierender finde denn ich kann mir kaum
vorstellen das ist die indigenen Völker Amerikas
so toll finden wenn ihr Nationalfeiertag auf
exakt das Datum fällt an dem Kolumbus gelandet ist
amerikanische Universitäten sind unfassbar
politisch korrekt und das ist insofern
absurd weil ja die Wissenschaft selbst
eigentlich politisch total unkorrekt ist
haben Affen und Menschen gemeinsame Vorfahren
wird Kindbettfieber durch Ärzte ausgelöst die
sich nicht die Hände gewaschen haben sind Frauen
genauso klug wie Männer das waren vor 100 Jahren
vor 150 Jahren politisch total unkorrekte
Fragen die man am liebsten unterdrückt hätte
und diese Fragen diese unbequemen
Fragen die gibt es ja heute auch noch
aber es werden nicht mehr gestellt weil wir unsere
Debattenkultur verloren haben nicht nur in der
Wissenschaft auch in normalen Leben auch auf der
Bühne man muss vorsichtig sein was man sagt ja
letzte Woche habe ich bei einem
Auftritt die Frage aufgeworfen ob
den sehbehinderte Menschen auch die Haufen
von ihren Blindenhunden wegmachen müssen
und wenn ja wie gehen die nach Geruch oder nach
passt sind ja war die Stimmung richtig im Keller
als ich vor 20 Jahren auf der Bühne angefangen
habe was vor allem wichtig Gags zu schreiben
bei denen die Leute lachen heute müssen sie Gags
schreiben bei denen die richtigen Leute lachen
wenn die falschen Leute lachen kannst dann
schon auch mal eng werden mit der Karriere
damals hat man als Kabarettist ja
auch noch ehrliche Kritiken bekommen
Ebert kalauerte sich durch den Abend hat
die Süddeutsche mal geschrieben flach und
uninspirierend die Frankfurter Rundschau
ich habe ja meine ersten Programme auch
ohne Pause gespielt weil im zweiten
Teil sonst der Saal der gewesen wäre
irgendwann hat dann Journalist zu
mir gesagt als er über dich kann
man das gar nicht erklären aber für ihr
Talent läuft inzwischen überraschend gut
das waren brutale aber es waren ehrlich Kritiken
heute werden sie als Kabarettist immer
weniger danach beurteilt ob sie originell
oder witzig oder kreativ sind sondern ob
sie sich zu etwas richtigen positionieren
Veranstalter hat neulich über die neue
Show von dem jungen Kollegen gesagt also
sie hat mir schon gewünscht dass der da eine
klare politische Haltung artikuliert hätte
meine Güte der Mann ist Pantomime
was soll der denn groß sagen
die politische Korrektheit überzieht unsere
Gesellschaft wie eine schleimige Hautkrankheit
und je länger dieser Zirkus andauert umso mehr
zerstören wir die größte Errungenschaft unserer
abendländischen Kultur sagen zu dürfen was man
denkt auch wenn es falsch dumm und unerträglich
ist das führt ja noch nicht einmal dazu dass die
Leute netter miteinander umgehen ganz im Gegenteil
schauen sie mal auf Facebook oder Twitter was
da los ist bist du ein linksgrün versiffter
Gutmensch oder ein rassistischer afdler in diesen
Kategorien spielt sich das ab über diese Fragen
zerbrechen langjährige Freundschaften ja
sogar Familien nach 30 Jahren ist dieses
Land auf einmal wieder geteilt nicht mehr in Ost
und West sondern in Dinkel und Dunkeldeutschland
[Applaus]